Jesus Christ founded his religion within
an empire the Roman Empire existed
before and what he was talking about was
all religion whereas Muhammad Ali
founded an empire we forget yet yes
right that's a very important
distinction really Anna might be the
crucial distinction and there was this
Empire and this Empire rose and declined
and fell and those who feel that they
have inherited that medicines they want
to go back to the days of empire yeah
for about three days well you know his
love was supreme and they want to do
this in the 21st century when wanting
all kinds it's not just that you can't
come on horseback and invade an existing
Empire in decline like this entire like
you know own home and suppose these
Asian empires that they took offering to
just take things also it's not like that
but they are driven them there convinces
they have this legacy and they're not
afraid of death and that is key because
and here's why I keep going back to down
all Muslim children learn that life on
this earth is temporary
yes first Italy and that there is
something in the here and it is not
poisoning except sin a teenager servants
so for the medina Muslims it really
becomes easy to recruit and inspire into
their parents Muslims who have already
been taught that they've only got to
work over here there are problems with
Islam and I think it was good understand
of course the basic elements of
Muhammad's wrong with all of the Quran
the fall of the hereafter all of these
things and what Sharia law truly means
and then we get to the dagger pass this
is how do they manage to teach young
people how do they manage to teach both
all these thousands and millions of
people who who is subsidizing these
countries like Saudi Arabia Qatar doing
etc once one understand that I think
that it makes our job as Westerners
worse than SS whatever easiest